benvenuti lunghissimo a grandissima
richiesta il video delle stato insomma
che dovrebbe comprendere i saldi
ecco il tasto dolente di saldo c'è molto
poco in quello che vi sto per mostrare
perché quest'anno non lo so perché
entravano i negozi dare un'occhiata ai
saldi e istintivamente me ne andavo
nella zona nuova collezione quindi
diciamo che di saldo e di occasioni
speciali ne ho trovati molto bacheca ma
visto che avete chiesto in tanti anche
se non ci sono tantissimi saldi voglio
farvi vedere le nuove cosine che ha
comprato in particolare una che come ho
anticipato su instagram è il regalo di
compleanno come sono una persona quindi
auto regalo e sono completamente
innamorata non vedo l'ora di farvelo
vedere
vi dico solo che è ancora dentro la
scatola non è stato proprio aperto
proprio per farlo live davanti a voi
quindi sono emozionatissima come se
fosse proprio il momento dell'acquisto e
e partirei subito iniziando dai vestiti
falso a destra e infine come al solito
vi lascio la chicca finale
allora io partirei con il denim il denim
è molto trendy da qualche annetto e
cercavo da tantissimo tempo una mini
nicola no diciamo che una gonna di jeans
bella leventina vitalità e non riusciva
a trovarla perché non
la mia taglia quindi l'ho trovata da
other stories e l'ho comprata
giustamente ma non c'è solo questo di
denim per fitch e anche questo
fantastico bellissima prestito sono per
me vorrei chiamare nostro pet no vestito
abbottonato ecco molto trendy molto
jennifer lopez land nel 2000 è molto
marina nel 2018 perché era passiamo ai
vestiti che io definirei coi fiocchi
perché in questo caso abbiamo appunto
questo mini vestitino mini dress rosa
sailor moon che è prettamente sarà così
indossato chiaramente fra l'altro
effetto comunque si fa un fiocco
quadranti sul décolleté e sei subito
pronta per un manga giapponese questo
invece è simile più lungo più
vacanze a capri me lo immagino vicino al
chiosco di caratteri dove fanno le
limonate passiamo ai pantaloni allora
d'estate si usano poco io però li amo in
particolare questa versione qui bella
fresca con un bel tacco un bel toppino
insomma favolosi io presi da poi show
che il mio nuovo negozio preferito e li
metterò quando andrò a bali compro le
cose pensando
insomma in quale paese diventerò no
scherza dimetterò comunque però diciamo
che sono molto mood molto esotico molto
aladdin e poi ho preso anche questi che
sono un pochino più pesanti di perfetti
per esempio per una passeggiata da chi
non è stato riceve anzitutto ci deve
andare e in provincia di trapani è un
paesino che cioè tipo un po in alto in
montagna guancia e non in montagna o
comunque ad alta quota e quindi anche
restate il festino perfetto per farsi
una passeggiata di con un bel toppino
nero così fa il torneo più o meno e più
giallo 69 prof
viaggiamo con la fantasia e soprattutto
è un pantalone che mi mette molto bene
in risalto le forme quindi copre ma in
realtà sottolinea sempre dauri show che
come vi ho detto è il mio nuovo negozio
preferito non ho comprato questa
bellissima vestaglia rosa per notti
magiche
prossimamente la indosserò o comparto
anche di ciabatte non le ho prese
aspettate se volete vedere
quanto sono oppose quanto sono rosa
quanto sono abbinate alla vestaglia per
notti magiche per una vera diva
hollywoodiana in decadenza
ecco dove riescono che si faccia dentro
e perosino quindi segregate nell'armadio
perché se le metto sulla destra da
agosto col caldo che fa è vissuta nei
piedi quindi queste le metterò in
inverno con i calzettoni quindi abbinano
ai calzettoni quindi tutto l'effetto
chic sexy di vende cadenza va insomma a
scemare
passiamo alle scarpe le scarpe sono le
uniche cose che ho acquistato con i
soldi che queste le ho già usate quindi
farò la finta di aprirlo in realtà sono
già state utilizzate ma la scatola è
questa sono this film ed è sono piene di
sabbia perché le utilizzate per andare
chiaramente il ristorante in spiaggia in
lizza quindi ho provato a togliere
rimasto per belli belli se avessi saputo
che c'era la sabbia insomma mi sarei
messa l'infradito
ma passiamo un altra scarpa di steve
madden
questa messa una volta ma non sia
ordinata quindi non ero in spiaggia un
suo prossimo sandalo modo che ho
comprato in abbinamento quello nero
perché chiaramente non puoi comprare una
scarpa oro o una scarpa stoner a tenere
comprare due per fare lascia con eros e
non andava bene
l'ultimo paio di scarpe di jessica
simpson voi in legno non saprete
assolutamente parlando ma chi è nato
negli anni novanta curione jessica
simpson era una cantante spa delle
scarpe adesso abbiamo scoperto che ha
una linea e su molto sobria una
fantastica zeppa sobria con delle perle
incastonate e penso che siano perfette
per andare in spiaggia e farsi notare
ok siamo arrivati al punto cruciale del
video come avete visto su una tabella
spedita perché dovevo arrivare in fretta
a questo momento molto emozionante
questa cosa che vi sto per far vedere la
volevo da un po di tempo e non c'è stata
nessuna cinese che me lo voleva rubare
come l'anno scorso
vi ricordate per la borsa di prada
perché non era il saldo quindi nessuno
mi correva dietro allora andata più o
meno così
avete presente quando hai un diavoletto
che ti parlo di qua e l'angioletto che
ti parla di lax ecco io entravo nel
negozio sono andata più volte tra
l'altro conosco anche una delle commesse
quindi fa animali due chiacchere aveva
brafam la vedevamo accarezzare
più bella la prova è lo specchio mandi
le foto tutta la famiglia
chiaramente a saldo bella bella bella e
cioè il diavoletto dice compra compra
compra dare compra compra e cioè
l'angioletto tecnici in aspetta cioè non
è in saldo quindi puoi aspettare e la
prendi che avanti non c'erano dei per
forza prenderlo adesso
pensaci bene magari tempo anche veri
comprando quindi visto che vi sono una
brava ragazza ho ascoltato l'angioletto
sembra sono comprata per il compleanno
ha detto qualche giorno fa io salvo se
volete fare un giretto e non avevo
assolutamente intenzione di comprare
lascia proprio non ci stavo pensando
però diciamo che qualcosa mi ha
trasportato davanti a questo negozio
l'istinto l'anima e lo spirito non lo so
comunque ero lì davanti e ho detto salvo
è arrivato il momento che anche tu
conosca questa cosa cioè la carezza
anche tu un po la guardia e mi dici cosa
ne pensi
sono bastati tre secondi perché io mi
sono provata questa cosa allo specchio
l'ho guardata ho guardato salvo ho
guardato il commercio detto ok la compro
mlb lahiri saint germain
signori e signore mariners e mariners
e arrivato il momento di farvi vedere il
mio regalo di compleanno
[Musica]
come vedete è intatto la busta non è
stata aperta cioè proprio sigillo qua
quindi ho aspettato di indossarla e per
farvela vedere live per aprirla insieme
a voi siete pronti
vado
no è troppo bella così non ce la faccio
[Musica]
purtroppo ragazzi non me la farò vedere
in questo video ve la farò vedere nel
prossimo video quindi mi raccomando
seguite scherzo ci siete cascati
no dai non sono così cattiva tutto il
video con lanteri vedere questa cosa la
faccio vedere siete prof
innanzitutto già percepiscono l'oro nero
e quindi già ci siamo
questo è di compleanno l'amo e e
mobilissima è bellissima e oro nero e
attualmente la borsa che desideravo è
troppo bella non ci sono parole
fatemi sapere se piace anche voi e io me
lo abbraccio lo sono abbastanza in ansia
perché sono un ragazzo abbastanza
sbadata quindi ho paura di rovinarla
graffiarla di carla e giuro
giuro che farò attenzione questa volta
perché è veramente un gioiellino molto
caos di essermi fatto questo regalo
finalmente abbiamo fatto vedere quindi
il video finisce qui e spero tantissimo
insomma che vi sia piaciuta la borsa che
sam piaciute tutte le altre cose che ho
comprato fatemelo sapere qui sotto nei
commenti
e io vi mando un bacione grazie per aver
visto il video
se non avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi al
mio canale eseguite su instagram per
vedere insomma tutti i vestiti e gli
acquisti che vi ho mostrato indossati
chiaramente ciao ragazzi un bacione
io continuo la serata con la mia bambina
[Musica]